the Royal matchmaker yeah how fun we
were just reading this in opposites it
looks like such a cute homework story
what was it like to be part of it it's a
really cute story it was so much fun to
be a part of we got will Kemp who has
not done a hallmark movie either so we
were both really excited to be a part of
it and to shoot in Romania which was
stunning is it as magical as I would
imagine it to be being part hallmark yes
absolutely and I gotta ask you I loved
seeing the women of One Tree Hill come
together and write that letter to mark
Schwahn he's now been let go relieved of
his position on the Royals how do you
feel about that I feel like that's the
best thing that could have ever happened
to him you know people who make bad
choices sometimes need to run into a
really strong brick wall before you wake
up and go is this the person I still
want to continue to be so I hope he you
know has that reckoning with himself and
maybe can turn things around and just
with all the allegations of assault
coming out in Hollywood what do we do to
move the conversation forward I think
that's the question of the day isn't it
you want it to be a conversation that
really moves somewhere and grows and I
think you know the time's up Fund is a
huge step in that direction I'm thrilled
about that
and I think a lot of its also going to
be you know connecting through social
media and having conversations with
people who believe things who see things
differently than you yeah listening
listen listen listen to someone whose
opinions drive you crazy and then be
willing to have a conversation with them
about it